Fabio the business media Gaza thanks
Connor I wasn't sure what we were gonna
do today
so is it the guy with Karl has what
twenty billion dollars yes or Larry who
oversees anyway four plus really
brilliant yeah I mean and the makeup of
those make a difference to how they want
to play it out you know of Larry's four
point six trillion about one trillion or
so is in passive ETS the only way that
he can proud perform with those you
can't sell the dogs in an ETF you're
stuck with them as much as any well so
all you can rely on is management to do
a better job and and you know and that
matters but you know in reality they
both have a very strong point fifty-four
percent of US corporate profits fifty
four percent have been spent on share
buybacks over the last decade that's a
tremendous amount of all the capital
that should be available to build things
and grow things and pay workers is going
you know is going to buy back shares and
it makes sense if the CEO is paid based
on options he want to seize that share
price up so I'm gonna have less shares
outstanding they don't move my strike
they keep my strike where it is in the
shares sure let's break that down in
English huh you're you're a CEO you own
there's a hundred thousand shares
outstanding that I'm white I'm American
you're the man you're halfway there and
you just need to fill in the form really
then you just get the title you know you
then go out and do your share buybacks
the share price owing to the reduction
of shares will go up and in many many
cases you don't see the option that
they're you know they're they're
management options change in strike
price so in other words that hundred
dollars that had been your strike maybe
the stock was up to ten percent because
you bought back ten percent not because
you actually did anything so it creates
a tremendous incentive to do that then
you have these so-called activists that
you know you use it as an excuse to some
degree and you look at that amount of
share buybacks fifty four percent of SP
profits
something's motivating that beyond Carl
Icahn and ten other guys yelling explain
it Fabio Carl Icahn centrist or at least
the CEOs interests are potentially more
aligned with Carl icons than they are
necessarily
long-term shareholders like Blackrock
it's interesting they are to some degree
but you know 17,000 directors went up
for vote in 2012 of those 17,000 only 60
did not get a majority of approval and
of those 60 only for status though only
six actually quit so Ikon must be going
crazy if you want to see management
turnover you got six guys come on well
is Larry think being realistic when you
think about his position he runs
Blackrock the largest asset manager in
the world he can get a meeting with any
company on the planet and for the most
part whether it's an IPO or debt
issuance he's gonna get the biggest if
not top three allocations out there so
is he really looking at what it's like
to be a real investor what it's like to
be an activist investor I mean Larry can
kind of do whatever he wants
well it's anything Larry takes great
pains to actually not be in a position
where he's ever seen to be able to vote
he has an entire 20 person team that
votes on a hundred and twenty thousand
plus corporate actions a year why
because one one of his clients calls up
the guy who's got you know the GM
pension fund he's also going to be the
same person that the activists are going
after so he's going to get a call from a
client also who also happens to be a
target of the pension funds and he's not
exactly covered in complete innocence
his own you know his small cap value
fund runs a turnover of around 130 140
percent a year if he wants to worry
about long term investing he could also
take the elevator down a few stories and
tell tell his own portfolio managers not
to be so concerned about quarterly
earnings you know they are there's
concerns different from a hedge fund
manager absolutely and so and they're
looking at what icon doesn't deciding
whether to pile on and join him or not
so who's right in the end is it Larry
Fink who accuses people like Carl Icahn
of short-termism
and the CEOs who roll over for Carl
Icahn similarly shorter missed you know
in the buy backs and and and dividend
increases that they did they implement I
you know on this one you look at the
holdings of Icahn cr-v Energy eBay Apple
those are like appellees held since 2013
CRV since 22 2012 eBay 2013 he's not a
pump-and-dump guy he's just not a
pump-and-dump guy and he's pumping dumb
activist investors who are giving a bad
name to the whole posse very very very
few and every academic study indicates
all of them they've been done and read
undefined do they underperform after
these events after the activists sell
how much do they pop beforehand and you
found absolutely no correlation at all
with poor performance afterwards
in other words if it was a pump and dump
there would be a price collapse
dan Lowe was out of Yahoo by the time
Marissa Meyer who he put in that job by
the time she sat in her seat Dan wasn't
in the trade anymore
but had he been the stock Sun well you
know he may he may well have gotten that
one wrong and I think what he wanted to
see was the process done that's where
the bulk of the activities worked he
might also have used the money to do
some other things no I'm saying people
criticize dan saying you know you were
out of the trade but guess what it's the
work it still worked it still worked and
you make a change you make an
intelligent change like that it does
work there you go
may never happen too long thanks Bobby
oh it's always a pleasure to have you on
Fabio salvo deli